I should mention now Pete just recorded
a brand new song with Adam Barda
really yeah that's Tam mom's producer
house Tam I feel about you working with
Adam was there did she say something
well I mean maybe she didn't say
anything but I can sense that how do you
sense it did you run into her no no yeah
I think just one vibe 35 but how do you
get a vibe get this from what what what
I wouldn't work what would I get
but did you see tan mom no I haven't
seen loca know what haven't seen her
spoken or just a sense I get just a
sense I'm good but you haven't seen
haven't seen or spoken to her so this is
just in his head
yeah just mine you think she's jealous
that you're working with Adam I would
room nothing to base it on nothin to
prove it but yeah right how do you like
the song did it come out good very good
yeah very good oh it's good did you
write this longer than Adam right why is
it can you sing on it yeah is Adam
singing on it balancing out what does he
need this thing on yeah you don't need
this help dude
so going back and forth what's the name
of this phone it's called in my opinion
in my opinion yeah and what is it about
it's about all about your opinion it's
about overcoming like a chat like a
challenge like out because of your
Tourette's yeah this is about you
overcoming Tourette's I think it was
written about that yeah I think so I
think I wrote it Adam Adam
Oh animal yeah you thought it sounded
like something you might sing yeah well
you can't omit with the idea because
it'll be there this song get messy for
me
[Music]
[Music]
you might just know where we're taking
my time losing man that Judge by people
with my house you can't see the things I
hope mr. your narrative buddy about me
[Music]
hell is all this time that atom pink in
the course wife's we got him you were
doing fine hey don't mind it [ __ ] you
on my song
[Music]
got you
okay Adam oh he speaks away to crowbar
himself him
listen in my opinion in my opinion get
weird his opinion in I don't know what
is a pig